there was no you had no choice where you
were going to lose that dog and who
wants to wait another 10 hours
that's right she said 10 hours she
wanted to help a dog out adopt a dog but
despite the animal foundation begging
the community for help she says it took
way too long to get in thanks for
joining us here at six o'clock I'm
Denise Valdez and I'm Brian Loftis the
animal foundation says they're being
flooded with animals and that's why they
are pleading with the community for help
and people want to help but now their
patience is running thin eight news now
reporter Victoria Saha speaking with
families who were trying to adopt and
shows us what a hassle it's been
Victoria
yeah Brian and Denise right now there
are over 700 animals inside the shelter
waiting on their forever homes but going
home it seems like it's going to take a
little bit longer for them as families
are coming here and finding out it's
been a hassle trying to go through
adoption
I'm now 10th in in line just to yeah
and they said it's still going to be a
few hours Donovan young showing up at
the animal foundation first thing
Tuesday morning with an appointment made
he was on a mission to
end he was his friend's dog recently
surrendered to the animal foundation
there's dogs that's been in here for
months and you know they they want to
put you on this waiting list do you
think you'll be able to walk out with a
dog today well I'm I'm willing to wait
for him you know because that's how
desperate I want the dog he's a really
good dog the animal foundation also
desperate to get the animals out this
past weekend they put out an emergency
alert stating that they don't have any
more space and to need 100 dogs to go
into foster homes it's nothing new their
own numbers show they took in more than
1700 animals in April about 280 went to
foster homes but in that same month more
than 140 were returned the airplane
prepared we went and got leashes
um food all that stuff we were ready for
our new dogs Christina Avila wanted a
dog for her kids soap she went to the
animal foundation Sunday morning now
it's
six o'clock now and I'm still at number
three nine hours later they found out
the dog they did want to adopt wasn't
adoptable why because it wasn't neutered
there was a lot of really great dogs in
there that could have went home with
somebody still wanting a dog for her
family she bought a puppy he was really
expensive but I didn't have it was a lot
more pleasant and we actually could
bring him home so that was it
so that man who wanted Gunner after all
that waiting he found out that Gunner
has already been fostered out and the
animal foundation tells me wait times
depend on where you are in line they
come as a first come first serve basis
Victoria Saha eight news now nine ten
hours is a very long time to wait if you
are looking to Foster or adapt the
animal foundation still needs your help
now there's a few steps though to try
and make it easier you can find the
animal you want by looking online and
then go ahead and fill out the paperwork
beforehand and we'll have those links
for you on our website at 8newsnow.com